we are
make no mistake the middle of an
enormous
uh multivariate kind of ponzi scheme
when you think about a ponzi scheme you
typically imagine a bernie madoff type
character
or maybe a big connect character
it's one guy selling an impossible
investment to a bunch of suckers
bernard madoff has just been sentenced
for the biggest investment fraud in wall
street history
madoff pleaded guilty to 11 felony
counts of securities fraud and perjury
in a ponzi scheme that robbed thousands
of unwitting investors
of tens of billions of dollars many of
them lost their entire life savings
the thought of something like the
epicenter of innovation that is silicon
valley being a giant ponzi scheme
doesn't really cross your mind we've got
an incredible opportunity to try to
uphold
a legacy in silicon valley of changing
the world and disrupting the world
we're working 24 7 to do it and that is
perhaps exactly why silicon valley and
the world of venture capital has been
able to slip
under the radar and grow to be perhaps
one of the biggest ponzi schemes in
human history
i'm sorry guys but like if you think
that that's not what's happening you're
lying to yourself
you are lying to yourself and here's how
you can profit from it
any ponzi scheme so to speak like
the people who are actually running it
they would
almost never really think that it's a
ponzi scheme in any way
either through lying to themselves or
simply by looking at other examples of
things where people don't call it a
ponzi scheme
this is arvid ali he created one of the
most successful consulting firms in
silicon valley and is currently
president of jordan belford's companies
for example your video on how the
banking world works
in some ways it does genuinely operate
like a ponzi scheme if you really think
about it
so it's taking a bunch of people's money
and then
lending it out to other people and then
trying to get more money from the people
that they lent it out to and then they
just keep
moving money back and forth between
their different customers it's not
inherently that different from most
ponzi schemes as it relates to
investments it's just
a slight little tweak that converts it
from being a legitimate
you know banking service versus being a
ponzi scheme if that makes sense
if you're going to build your own vc
firm or be a business person in general
you're gonna eventually need to work
with people from all over the world in
our ever more connected economy
that's why this video is proudly
sponsored by babel the number one
language learning app in the world with
more than 10 million subscriptions
worldwide
this is the app i use and it really does
make learning another language enjoyable
and easy
and it definitely helped with the
russian mafia video
[Music]
you can choose from 13 different
languages you can learn in easy to
digest 10 to 15 minute chunks
and what's unique about babel is that
universities have shown that just 21
hours on babble
is equal to an entire college course at
pennies on the dollar
stick to the end to learn more or pause
the video and click on the link in the
video description to get up to 65
off a baffle subscription for a limited
time only with a 20 day money back
guarantee that's up to 65
off with the link below it all starts
with an idea a new app a new platform
preferably from young naive not business
savvy founders
but not just any idea a disruptive idea
an idea is so good that it will for sure
turn this industry upside down the next
uber of whatever
or at least that's what the entrepreneur
hopes maybe in reality it's just an
okay idea maybe in reality it's a
terrible idea that will never be
profitable
but that's besides the point you just
needed to sound like a disruptive tech
startup
because tech startups have the allure of
being able to grow super fast
where you can double quadruple 10x 100x
your investment
but in reality you're really just
bringing in existing technology like a
pretty website and mobile app into an
existing industry
so the founder manages to get the
startup going but they run into a
problem
the revolutionary idea needs a lot more
upfront capital to get to the next stage
maybe they're worried that their idea is
so good that bigger companies with more
money are just gonna take their idea and
outspend them
or maybe they just want to make it big
get rich get famous fast
it's reasonable to compare you i usually
don't do this to steve jobs and what he
did for computing
whatever the reason is they need money
but banks are never going to give
business loans out to risky startups
something like three out of every four
startups fail banks are never going to
take that kind of risk
luckily that's where we come in the
venture capital firms or vcs for short
so what you'll often find is that vc
firms really specifically want to invest
into companies
where the founders are really young guys
is because they want them to essentially
act as slaves
for them so what you'll find is that
these founders are working all day and
night
to effectively act as these slaves for
these firms
who dictate exactly what they need to be
doing
so step number two you come in and say
hey we want to partner with you you're
the best we're gonna help you're so
awesome
have a fleece fest
we backed blah blah company you know
right that's the whole that's the basic
that's the pitch
so you start to court them but not as an
individual investor that's putting their
own money on the line
these are not people writing checks out
of their own balance sheet they're doing
a job with other people's money
no you're what amounts to a fund manager
who knows a lot of rich people
rich people who don't like having a
bunch of cash on hand since it just goes
down in value
so they give a tiny portion of their
cash to vc firms like yourself
in hopes that you'll invest their money
in the next big thing
startups that will give them huge
returns that they're never gonna find
anywhere else
in exchange for a fee of course here's
how it works investors hand the vc firm
money to be locked up in the fund for 10
years or more
the fund managers collect a two percent
fee on the amount of money under
management per year for the first four
years
also known as the active investment
period which may or may not be all that
active
then they take around a 1.5 fee for the
remaining six years
so if you raise a 100 million dollar
fund you're guaranteed to make a minimum
of 17 million dollars
no matter if the companies you choose go
up down sideways whatever
17 million practically all going into
your pocket says there isn't much
overhead all the money pretty much goes
directly into the pockets of the people
running the vc firm so
it's often the the main person who
created the firm as well as
the partners that he or she brought in
and a little bit goes to
the few employees that they have the
reason they really haven't any employees
is because the work that they actually
have to do is next to nothing
it's very typical for uh many of the
employees to become millionaires very
quickly
but on top of that even if you're just
randomly picking startups
some of them are bound to do well and if
they do you get 20
of those gains also known as the carry
if
one out of every 10 startups you choose
does well you take from the top
and leave the losses for your investors
to carry
so back to step one you offered the
startup let's say
one million dollars in exchange for a
percentage of their company
we'll call this the series a funding
round along with the 1 million
offer you put the valuation of the
startup at 6 million
meaning that a 1 million investment at
the valuation of 6 million
gives you around a 17 ownership in the
company
the startup gets a million dollars to
grow faster the founders feel great
because they built a million dollar
company
you and your investors get a share in an
early stage startup that could make it
big
but perhaps most importantly you collect
those juicy management fees on that one
million dollars invested
and then comes the first board meeting
with your new company and you ask
how fast are you growing okay grow
faster
how many of you have had that discussion
grow faster okay most of you that raised
your hand
just grow faster yes we want to see
massive growth okay but we were kind of
hoping to improve the product a little
more before we go after a larger
audience nope it's good to go
massive growth got it okay well these
investors know what they're talking
about so the founders take your money
and grow faster
[Music]
step number three grow super fast the
founders take the millions you gave them
and shove them into things like facebook
ads
instagram ads youtube ads amazon
services it would probably shock you
to know that almost 40 cents of every
venture dollar right now goes right back
into the hands of google facebook and
amazon
basically you get them to do whatever it
takes to grow
on paper because that's all that matters
do you think that's all profitable
growth
no that's there to fund
your superficial growth more users more
sales more revenue don't worry if the
company isn't profitable or sustainable
don't worry about things like whether or
not the product is actually getting
better
if the product market fit is actually
getting better don't worry if it costs
100
to acquire a new user when it only
brings in ten dollars in revenue each
just spend as much money as possible to
get more customers more growth
we'll figure out how to be profitable
later just because the entrepreneur or
the vc gives you a million dollars and
tells you to grow faster
do you have better product market fit in
that moment no
you're doing what you're told to do
which is to take their money and make
the company grow
remember we want to keep the illusion
going that this is one of those
disruptive tech platforms that have to
be unprofitable before they can
skyrocket in money
like amazon or facebook but in reality
what's really going on is
they take advantage of that narrative by
simply saying hey
let's make sure that we have absolutely
no profit and let's just show that we're
getting a lot of users the same way that
instagram or facebook on users
and as long as we're showing that
engagement growth
then uh we'll be able to raise a lot of
money the problem is the second we show
any profitability
that that happens they'll bucket us as a
normal company and not a hyper growth
company so
the funny thing is like i know a lot of
silicon valley companies that are worth
well over a billion dollars
and when i speak to the founders what
they'll say is
the second the company even starts to
turn a profit the vc firms will say
hey don't ever show a profit immediately
you know show that you're running at a
loss
because we can't ruin the narrative that
um it's a hyper growth company
which brings us to step number four
running out money
so a year or so passes by and the
founders spent all your money
but look the startup you pick grew their
user base by 400
their sales skyrocketed by 400 percent
so you the vc are thinking to yourself
man
i'm pretty good at this i gotta tell my
friends hey vc bob look at this startup
i just invested in
they're gonna be the next uber of one
night stands and guess what
since investing in them our investment
has grown by 400 percent dude you gotta
get in on this action
they turn around to their buddies and
say look at this thing it's growing you
should do the b
so you go back to your board meeting and
say hey guys good job
but if we want to keep this string going
we're gonna need to raise more money
and then they come into a board meeting
they're like guys i think we should
raise a b
which brings us to step number five the
series b
round when you invested that was called
the series a funding round
the second funding round at startup goes
through is logically called the series b
so your pals in another vc fund throw in
a few million dollars of their investors
money to secure
their spot in the company you and your
vc fan agree on an even more ridiculous
valuation number to make yourselves look
good
and in the next board meeting vc bob
asks hey
how fast are you going oh okay
take this money and grow faster so 40
cents of every dollar from the series b
money also gets thrown into facebook
google and amazon to buy more
unsustainable growth it's not even clear
that those ltvs
and those cats make any sense doesn't
matter you've been told to grow
so you're growing you're doing your job
which leads us into step number six
[Music]
another year or so passes by and would
you look at that we're all out of cash
but hey we just had another fantastic
year of growth
so vc bob is also led to thinking that
man our investment is doing so well but
we need more money to keep it growing
we should raise the series c we're
running out of money well of course york
because 40 cents of every dollar just
went back into the hands of facebook
google and amazon
so your friend vc bop shows off their
returns to their friends in another vc
firm
that buddy is like yeah this looks great
boom fire the money in
they raised a few more millions for the
c funding around completing step number
seven
and throughout all these funding rounds
since all the vcs are buddy buddy
they can value these companies at
whatever valuation they want
the higher the valuation you guys make
up the higher your paper returns look to
attract more investors the higher the
net worth of the founders investors
the guy that started the company he's
very happy he's like never even knew if
he could ever grow a business or
something like that and also now he's
got this business that who knows might
have a valuation of hundreds of millions
of dollars or a billion dollars and he's
got
you know a 10 ownership 20 ownership in
this he's
he's incredibly happy he just got
insanely rich and as long as you guys
can convince the public of this
valuation by the time the company goes
public
the higher your payday when you cash out
so your goal is to make up the highest
possible valuation that the public is
willing to believe
why do you think wework was valued at
over 40 billion dollars at its peak
the best case scenario is for them to be
so large
that they end up getting they end up
going public
what you're trying to do is push it off
so that the general public
is dumping their hard-earned money into
your business
either through the standard ipo process
or more commonly nowadays through the
back door process
being the stack so back to our series c
funding round
now a has an even better markup b
has a markup c has a basis and is like
hey how fast are you growing maybe you
should grow faster
which brings us to my favorite steps
that number eight look like a genius
see when you invested you guys settled
on a valuation of six million dollars
well by the time the second vc firm
invested the company grew by
percent so bob's vc firm settled on a
valuation of let's say
24 million dollars that means to you and
your investors in just
one year you for extra money on paper
so you're feeling pretty smart right now
i'm practically the warren buffett of
startups
the guy who runs fun day is like i
should raise a second fund
i'm pretty good at this
and goes to a bunch of investors and
says look at my irr
they're amazing so for step number nine
you start a second fund to invest in
more startups
to have more money under management
collecting those juicy management fees
starting the process
all over except this time instead of
raising money from your rich investor
friends
you have a track record you can now
target even bigger investors
institutional investors like pension
funds
and endowments maybe for your first fund
you raise a puny 10 million dollars
so maybe for your second fund you're
able to raise 50 million a hundred
million
by the time the series c d e comes
around for the original startup
and all the artificial growth that comes
with it your friend bob and the second
vc firm that got in is also feeling
pretty confident
it would be a waste not to put your
minus touch on more startups so vc bob
also starts another fun to start the
process all over again
and then somewhere between the c and the
d the b guys are like
i'm pretty good at this this is easier
than i i should raise a second fund
maybe i'll make it a slightly bigger
fund i should be doing bigger checks
which brings us to the final step the
exits
a few years have gone by the founders
all the vc firms that invested in the
series a
b c d e and so on have made a ton of
money
on paper and if they want to cash in on
all those earnings to realize those
gains
they can either sell the company to one
of the big dogs facebook google amazon
and the like
which isn't optimal you're not gonna get
as much money out of that but it's
better than nothing
or they can take the company public
which is where the real money is at
the idea is to get so large that it's
not really reasonable for most companies
to even
be able to acquire you because uh
because the valuation is insane so
if you can't then the best thing you can
do is to get acquired
but the only problem with getting
acquired is that there's only you know
some set of companies that have the
money and interest
in acquiring you so if you can exit and
cash all your earnings great
you'll get a part of that money from
selling the company 20 of the gains
your investors will get the rest and
everyone is happy
if however the company goes under and
you guys can't sell the company
also great sure you won't get the bonus
from the exit but hey
you've been collecting the management
fee as the fund managers this whole time
you don't feel any of that loss
but for your investors three out of
every startups fail
it's no big deal one of the other
startups we have your money and will
make up for it don't worry
so whatever happens everyone is happy
this
is what's happening now so
when you wake up every day and you
notice
that umpteen companies are getting
funded for every single idea
and then that the quantum of dollars are
going up and that all of a sudden you're
reading about investors you've
never ever heard of
that is what something like this looks
like played out in real life
but there's one of beto flaw in this
entire scheme
the only reason this whole thing worked
is not necessarily because it was a
great company a great idea or great
execution
after all most of these companies are
just regular businesses sprinkled with a
little tech
but because of the same reason why any
ponzi scheme works
the money kept coming in the more money
came in the more unsustainable growth
could be bought from google facebook and
amazon
these are fundamentally broken business
concepts they don't work
they only work if the money never stops
the more growth that was bought
the more investors it attracted the more
funds were started it's just a little
ponzi scheme but think about it if any
way along
the the money stop coming in the
business fail
the higher the valuations are set the
more money the people who got in early
in this game of musical chairs made
johnny private equity was only thing
that kept alive so it could grow even
more
at a huge faster rate which would push
up the valuation even more so these guys
all look like geniuses and they all make
their fees on it
but as soon as the day arrives when the
money stops coming in
the music is gonna stop and whoever is
left without a seat
is screwed let's say this guy couldn't
grow any more money let's say johnny
private equity didn't want to buy in you
know where this goes
it goes to bankruptcy it goes to zero
the valuation goes to zero
but the money never stops until as much
time as people can raise new funds
and that's predicated on people marking
up old deals why is all this happening
all over the startup scene right now as
we speak the same reason why any other
corruption happens
the incentives generally speaking the
actual
employees themselves as well as the
founders of these companies have
absolutely no idea what's funny is even
for me
i actually had no idea that this was
going on despite the fact that i worked
with
hundreds of silicon valley companies
over many many years i couldn't even
get a sense of that because all you see
is these people working so hard
and how could you ever think that all
these people working so hard to build a
product
and uh to get customers that what
they're building is useless
isn't a real business so you never
really think that once you're inside of
the bubble but
the second you leave that bubble and you
get into the mindset
of the financial industry and you
actually create a vc firm
that's that's how i uh uh came to terms
with what's really going on and then i
verified with with
some billionaires in the finance
industry and that's kind of when i got a
perspective on what was really going on
after the vc managers placed the money
into startups there's not really much to
do
on top of that it doesn't matter if
growing at 400 isn't sustainable
because by the time the company runs out
of artificial growth to buy
the vc firm will be out there cash in
hand that's why the game is more about
placing your money than finding the best
startups to invest in
you see how this whole thing like at no
point is there anything that comes back
to you the entrepreneur that says
what's your true core product market fit
and is it working
it's not part of the conversation that
is extremely dangerous
now the majority of people in the vc
world aren't aware this is what they're
perpetuating
for the most part they're just doing
what they see as the best choice for
them in the moment
is this a bubble and is it gonna burst
it's hard to say
but the reality is people are greedy
it is a very large bubble but
it's impossible to say whether a bubble
is actually ever going to pop or
even if it does pop whether it pops in a
meaningful enough way
to stop the practice so if you really
look at
a lot of industries that have that have
typically had bubbles let's say real
estate
um especially with the housing market
even when
the bubble like temporarily contracts
there's usually enough incentive for
people to keep going on with the trades
what allows people to keep the housing
market uh the way it is now
it's still ridiculous that the prices of
homes have no bearing on
on reality because people are able to
get 30-year loans that they
need to spend an entire lifetime paying
back so it doesn't make any sense same
thing with with higher education
these bubbles yes it'll contract but the
problem is that
there's a psychosis in society that's so
extreme to say
that regardless of the price uh this is
such a valuable thing to do that i'm
just gonna
go ahead and do it so in the startup
world yeah in people's mind they're
thinking like oh
if only i got a chance to be one of the
early investors in facebook
i would be a millionaire a billionaire
right now so that
notion of gambling and the sexiness to
it
um is so alluring that i don't really
foresee that
the bubble will completely you know
burst in any specific way
am i or any of my affiliates calling vc
firms silicon valley specs or whatever
directly a scam
no so don't sue me bro all i'm trying to
say is that we all dream of getting rich
quick
which is legitimately possible but this
is a gentle reminder that the grow at
all cost mentality can be dangerous
and that real growth is always better
than paper growth
so obviously the only logical next step
is to start your own vc firm
that's what i'm gonna do and it's gonna
be called tran capital
invest now if you do start your own vc
firm or if you have
any big business aspirations whatsoever
you're probably gonna have to talk to
rich people who have money to invest but
are maybe from out of the country a
foreign investor
maybe their english is not too good
maybe their english is good but it's not
their native language
so if you really want to wow them if you
want to instantly stick out from the
masses of people always asking them for
money speak their native tongue
hell learn just a few phrases like hello
thank you and watch their ears instantly
perk up with a smile on their face
why because where everyone else is
thinking what can i get from this person
you show them that you care enough to go
out of your way to learn their culture
this doesn't just apply to selling
yourself to investors by the way it
could be the mentor you want the girl
the girl's parents the employer you want
to wow
and that is why i am very proud to have
babel as a sponsor of this video
the number one language learning app in
the world with more than 10 million
subscriptions worldwide
you can choose from 13 different
languages and it has a 4.5 star rating
from over 750
000 reviews on both the google play
store and the apple store
and where babel really shines compared
to other language learning apps
is that instead of wasting your time
learning words you will never use in
real life
babble gets right into the meat teaching
you phrases you'll actually use in real
life
and for a limited time babble is
offering you aspiring international
business people
up to 65 off a balable subscription so
you can start learning a new language
right now in bite size 10 to 15 minute
chunks with the link below
and they have a risk-free 20-day
money-back guarantee so get up to 65
off right now by clicking the link in
the video description
guys huge shout out to my friend arvid
ali who you've seen like sprinkled
throughout this entire video because
without his help this video definitely
wouldn't have been possible
arvid is also a pretty sharp guy he's
the current president of jordan
belford's companies yes the real wolf of
wall street he's an advisor to like 50
celebrities billionaires corporations
and prior to this he built one of the
most successful consulting firms in
silicon valley
so he was the perfect person to help out
with this video he just created a
youtube channel of his own where he's
gonna be going over more
secrets that he's learned as a true
insider so if you enjoyed this stuff
show him some love from the tran mafia
family by subscribing to his new channel
with the link below
while you subscribe to his channel with
the link in the video description you
might as well subscribe to this channel
too
if you are new here because we make
video essays just like this one every
single week on the most provocative
thought-provoking stuff in the world of
business instagram we have a lot of fun
over there you can follow me on
jaytrend.io if you want like memes
behind the scenes stuff me
complaining about stuff and cool quotes
that i come across in my own research
that you're not going to find anywhere
else
that is going to wrap it up for this
video thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous out there and i'll see
you guys in the next one
you